♪ ♪
>> Chris: A WEEK AGO WE TOLD
YOU ABOUT A BIPARTISAN GROUP OF
LAWMAKERS WHO PUT TOGETHER A
COMPROMISE PACKAGE FOR
CORONAVIRUS RELIEF.
IT LOOKED THEN LIKE IT MIGHT
SAIL THROUGH, BUT NO LONGER.
JOINING US NOW FROM
WEST VIRGINIA,
SENATOR JOE MANCHIN, A LEADING
MEMBER OF THE GANG OF EIGHT
PUSHING THAT PLAN.
SENATOR , IS THE GANG OF EIGHT’S
COMPROMISE, $908 BILLION, IS
THAT PLAN NOW DEAD AND IS THERE
A CHANCE THAT CONGRESS MAY LEAVE
TOWN FOR THE YEAR WITHOUT
PASSING ANY COVID RELIEF AT ALL?
>> Senator Manchin: FIRST OF
ALL, CHRIS, THE PLAN IS ALIVE
AND WELL AND THERE’S NO WAY, NO
WAY THAT WE ARE GOING TO LEAVE
WASHINGTON WITHOUT TAKING CARE
OF THE EMERGENCY NEEDS OF OUR
PEOPLE.
IN MY STATE OF WEST VIRGINIA
TOO.
THEY ARE ALL HURTING EVERYWHERE.
>> Chris: BUT IT SEEMS YOU’VE
GOT -- I’M GOING TO GET INTO
SOME SPECIFICS IN A MINUTE -- IF
GOT THE PRESIDENT PUSHING ONE
PLAN, THE SENATE MAJORITY LEADER
McCONNELL PUSHING ANOTHER,
NANCY PELOSI AND THE DEMOCRATS A
THIRD.
YOU KNOW, IT SEEMED, AS I SAY, A
WEEK AGO LIKE MAYBE THEY WERE
ALL GOING TO COME TOGETHER
BEHIND YOUR PLAN.
THERE’S AN AWFUL LOT OF TALK
THAT NEGOTIATIONS HAVE FALLEN
APART.
>> Senator Manchin: HERE’S THE
THING, IT HASN’T FALLEN APART.
WE’VE BEEN MEETING DAY AND NIGHT
FOR THE LAST MONTH.
WE WERE ON A CALL ALL DAY
YESTERDAY, WE GET ON A CALL
TODAY THIS AFTERNOON TO FINISH
THINGS UP.
WE WILL HAVE A BILL PRODUCED FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TOMORROW,
$908 BILLION.
CHRIS, THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THERE’S A LOT OF PARTS TO THIS
BILL WHEN IN THE SPIRIT OF
COMPROMISE, YOU HAVE TO WORK
THROUGH ALL OF THAT.
BUT AT THE END, YOU CAN’T LET
THE PERFECT BE THE ENEMY OF THE
GOOD.
THIS GOING TO BE INDIVIDUALLY --
THERE SOME MEMBERS WHO WOULDN’T
VOTE FOR CERTAIN PARTS OF THE
BILL WHEN YOU PUT THEM
ALTOGETHER AND LOOK AT THE GOOD
IT DOES FOR OUR COUNTRY, IN THE
MOST EMERGENCY WAY THAT WE
NEEDED.
THIS IS ONLY UNTIL APRIL THE
ONE.
WE ARE TRYING TO GET THROUGH THE
TOUGHEST FIRST QUARTER OF OUR
COUNTRY THAT WE’VE EVER FACED
AND WE’VE GOT PEOPLE WITHOUT
NUTRITION.
WE HAVE PEOPLE WITHOUT SHELTER,
WE HAVE PEOPLE WITHOUT
PAYCHECKS.
THEY’RE UNEMPLOYED.
IF WE HAVE HOSPITALS BEING
OVERBURDENED.
WE HAVE HEALTH CARE WORKERS.
WE HAVE SCHOOLS THAT NEED TO BE
ATTENDED TO.
THIS COVERS ALL OF THAT AND WE
GET ALL THE SMALL BUSINESSES A
CHANCE TO SURVIVE AND KILL THE
FIRST QUARTER.
BY THEN WE SHOULD START TO COME
OUT WITH A VACCINE THAT SHOULD
BE HELPING US AT JOE BIDEN WILL
BE OUR PRESIDENT AND MAKE A
DETERMINATION WHAT MORE IS
NEEDED.
THIS IS STRICTLY AN EMERGENCY
MEASURE.
>> Chris: BUT I JUST WANT TO
MAKE IT CLEAR, THE BILL YOU’RE
TALKING ABOUT TOMORROW IS A BILL
THAT THE GANG OF EIGHT AGREES
ON.
YOU DON’T HAVE MAJORITY SUPPORT
IN THE SENATE.
IN THE HOUSE.
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT SOME OF THE
ALTERNATIVES THAT ARE OUT THERE
NOW AND LET’S -- IF YOU DON’T
MIND, A LIGHTNING ROUND, QUICK
QUESTIONS, QUICK ANSWERS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS FORGET --
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS FORGET THE
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS, JUST SEND
A SINGLE STIMULUS CHECK, $600,
TO EACH AMERICAN.
IS THAT A GOOD IDEA?
>> Senator Manchin: IT’S A BAD
IDEA AND I HOPE HE REEVALUATES
BECAUSE BASICALLY IF YOU’RE
SENDING STIMULUS CHECK OF $600
OR WHATEVER IT MAY BE.
IT WAS 1200 BEFORE, YOU’RE
SENDING IT TO PEOPLE THAT STILL
HAVE A PAYCHECK, THAT STILL HAVE
A JOB.
IF YOU SEND A CHECK TO AN
UNEMPLOYED PERSON YOU ARE
SENDING A PERSON THAT HAS NO
LIFELINE, IT’S DONE AT THE END
OF THIS MONTH.
THEY’VE GOT NOTHING.
$300 EXTENDED FOR 16 WEEKS.
I THINK THAT’S MUCH MORE
REASONABLE, PRACTICAL AND
MUCH-NEEDED.
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT,
REPUBLICAN LEADERS STILL WANT
SOME LIABILITY PROTECTION FOR
BUSINESSES SO PEOPLE WHEN THEY
GO TO A RESTAURANT OR SCHOOL OR
WHATEVER CAN’T THEN SUE AND SAY
YOU GAVE ME COVID.
DEMOCRATS STILL WANT A LOT OF
AID TO CITIES AND STATES, BUT
THE REPUBLICANS DON’T LIKE THE
DEMOCRATIC IDEA, THE DEMOCRATS
DON’T LIKE THE REPUBLICAN IDEA.
IS THAT STILL THE HOLD UP?
>> Senator Manchin: THE SPIRIT
OF COMPROMISE IS THIS.
EVERYBODY’S NOT GOING TO GET
WHAT THEY WANT.
WE CAN GET SOMETHING WE CAN ALL
LIVE WITH BUT WE ARE PUTTING A
PRODUCT FORWARD.
IT’S GOING TO GO FORWARD WITH
BOTH, WITH EVERYTHING HOPEFULLY
IN IT.
YOU WILL SEE A COMPLETE BUILD
TOMORROW BEFORE THE END OF THE
DAY.
YOU CAN CHOOSE IF YOU LIKE IT OR
NOT.
VOTE FOR IT OR VOTE AGAINST IT.
LOOK AT THAT GOOD IT DOES AS A
WHOLE, NOT AN INDIVIDUAL PIECE.
THERE’S NOBODY THAT WANTS A
BUSINESS TO BE LITIGATED OUT OF
BUSINESS.
THERE ARE GOING TO BE TOUGH
ENOUGH TO SURVIVE ME.
ON THE OTHER HAND, WE DON’T WANT
TO THROW CAUTION TO THE WIND
THAT THE BUSINESSES AREN’T SAFE
PLACES TO WORK, THE WORKERS ARE
NOT PROTECTED AND THE PEOPLE
THAT PATRONIZE THESE PLACES OF
BUSINESSES ARE NOT IN A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT.
WE HAVE TO TAKE ALL THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION AND DO THE BEST WE
CAN.
I REMIND YOU THIS, IT’S FOR A
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
A SHORT PERIOD.
WE ARE NOT CHANGING THE LAWS
FOREVER, WE’RE JUST TRYING TO
GET THROUGH AN EMERGENCY PERIOD
OF TIME.
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT.
SOME SENATORS ARE SAYING LOOK,
LIABILITY IS AN ISSUE, AID TO
CITY AND STATES AS AN ISSUE,
LET’S FORGET ABOUT BOTH OF THOSE
IN THIS BILL AND JUST STICK AID
SPECIFICALLY TO UNEMPLOYED
WORKERS AND AID TO SMALL
BUSINESSES ON THE BILL THAT
YOU’VE GOT TO FAST TO KEEP THE
GOVERNMENT RUNNING TO AVOID A
SHUTDOWN.
FORGET ABOUT THAT OTHER STUFF
FOR NOW.
WHAT TO THINK ABOUT THAT IDEA?
>> Senator Manchin: CHRIS,
THAT’S THE EASY WAY.
THAT’S THE EASY WAY OUT.
WE CAN FORGET ABOUT THE TOUGH
THINGS.
THAT’S WHAT WE’VE BEEN DOING FOR
TEN YEARS OR MORE.
NO ONE WANTS TO TAKE A TOUGH
VOTE.
THEY ARE ALL AFRAID IT’S GOING
TO HURT THEM IN THE ELECTION.
WE ARE HERE TO HELP OUR COUNTRY
THAT’S HAVING A TREMENDOUS
HARDSHIP GOING ON RIGHT NOW AND
IT’S GOING TO GET WORSE BEFORE
IT GETS BETTER.
SO WITH THAT BEING SAID, THAT’S
THE EASY WAY.
WE CAN DROP OFF BOTH LIABILITY
AND DROP OFF AID TO STATES, BUT
STATES AND MUNICIPALITIES
ESPECIALLY, THEY ARE ON THE
FRONT LINE.
YOU WANT YOUR SERVICES TO GO,
ESSENTIAL SERVICES?
FIRST RESPONDERS, FIREMEN,
POLICEMEN?
YOU WANT OTHERS TO BE IN
JEOPARDY?
THE SERVICES THAT WE DEPEND ON
AND NEED, LET IT FALL APART AND
THINK WE CAN PICK IT BACK UP?
TO WANT THE AIRLINES TO
COLLAPSE, ALL THESE THINGS TO GO
BY THE WAYSIDE?
WE DON’T.
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE THE TOUGH
SELECTION.
IF THE REST OF THE CAUCUS WON’T
GO ALONG WITH IT, THEY WILL
DECIDE WHAT THEY CAN THROW IT
OUT.
IF THE LEADERS CAN COME
TOGETHER -- WE WORKED AS A
BIPARTISAN GROUP AND WE’VE GROWN
OVER THE MONTHS.
WE GOT A GOOD PRODUCT THAT’S
BEEN VETTED IN SO MANY DIFFERENT
WAYS THE ONLY THING I CAN TELL
YOU, WE’VE DONE WHAT THIS PLACE
IS SUPPOSED TO DO.
WE WORKED TOGETHER.
WE DIDN’T WORK APART AND CONDEMN
EACH OTHER AND POINT FINGERS, WE
GOT A GOOD PRODUCT AND WE WANT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO KNOW THAT
AMERICA, WE CAN DO IT IN A
BIPARTISAN WAY, WE CAN DO IT AND
WE ARE GOING TO DO IT.
>> Chris: SENATOR MANCHIN,
YOU’VE DONE A VERY GOOD JOB OF
SELLING YOUR PLAN.
YOU HAVE NOT DONE A GOOD JOB OF
CONVINCINGLY THOUGH IT’S GOING
TO GET PASSED BY CONGRESS IN THE
NEXT WEEK.
>> Senator Manchin: THERE’S NO
GUARANTEE.
THERE’S 535 PEOPLE THAT HAVE TO
VOTE.
535.
I CAN’T GUARANTEE THEY’RE ALL
GOING TO VOTE FOR IT AND PASS IT
I CAN TELL YOU ONE THING, WHAT’S
THE ALTERNATIVE?
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
WE WOULD GIVE THEM ONE MONTH DAY
AND NIGHT, OUR STAFFS HAVE
WORKED AROUND-THE-CLOCK.
WE’VE DONE EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
PUT AN ALL-INCLUSIVE PRODUCT
TOGETHER.
PICK WHATEVER PARTS YOU LIKE,
WHATEVER PARTS YOU DON’T LIKE,
PUT IT ALTOGETHER OR TAKE IT AS
A WHOLE.
WE ARE GOING TO GIVE IT TO YOU
THE WAY WE THINK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE NEEDED IN AN EMERGENCY
SITUATION, WE NEED THIS
LEGISLATION.
>> Chris: SENATOR MANCHIN, I
WANT TO SWITCH TO JUST ONE OTHER
SUBJECT.
WE’VE GOT SHORT -- LESS THAN
2 MINUTES LEFT.
DO ANY OF JOE BIDEN’S NOMINEES,
MEMBERS OF HIS TEAM GIVE YOU
HEARTBURN?
FOR INSTANCE, BACK WHEN
BARACK OBAMA APPOINTED DR. VIC
MURPHY AS SURGEON GENERAL, YOU
OPPOSED THAT.
HE IS NOW BEING RENAMED BY
JOE BIDEN FOR SURGEON GENERAL.
YOU’VE GOT JAVIER BECERRA FOR
HHS.
IS THERE ANYBODY THAT HE HAS
NAMED SO FAR THAT YOU THINK I’M
NOT SURE I CAN VOTE TO CONFIRM
THEM?
>> Senator Manchin: LET ME BE
VERY CLEAR, I’VE BEEN VERY
DIFFERENTIAL -- DEFERENTIAL WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP,
PRESIDENT OBAMA’S AND I WILL BE
VERY DIFFERENTIAL WITH
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
I THINK A PRESIDENT KNOCKED UP
PUT THEIR TEAM TOGETHER.
UNLESS THAT PERSON HAS DONE
SOMETHING WRONG OR WHAT TOTALLY
RUNS AMOK OF WHAT I BELIEVE,
THEN BASICALLY I ALWAYS HAVE
SAID OKAY, PUT YOUR TEAM
TOGETHER.
IF THEY SCREW UP AND THEY ARE
BAD, YOU’RE GOING TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND IN FOUR YEARS,
THE PEOPLE CAN ATONE THAT.
SO I’VE BEEN VERY DIFFERENTIAL.
I’M GOING TO LOOK AT EACH ONE OF
THEM.
THERE MIGHT BE SOME THAT I DON’T
AGREE WITH.
I WILL BE ABLE TO LET THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION KNOW HOW I FEEL
BUT WE HAVEN’T DONE THE PERSONAL
INTERVIEWS YET BEFORE WE
CONFIRM.
I LOOK FORWARD TO THAT.
>> Chris: SENATOR MANCHIN,
THANK YOU, THANKS FOR JOINING US
AND GOOD LUCK THIS WEEKEND
COMING UP WITH A LOOP RELIEF
PACKAGE, OR ANOTHER COUNTRY
NEEDS IT.
THANK YOU, SIR.
>> Senator Manchin: CHRIS, WE
ARE GOING TO DO IT.
PEOPLE BELIEVE IN AMERICA.
THIS IS A GREAT COUNTRY AND THE
PEOPLE NEED HELP RIGHT NOW, SO
WE CAN BE GREAT AGAIN, AND WE